[Music]  the Cleveland Cavaliers select LeBron  James there's no question there's no  pressure at all I've been getting  pressure since I was 10 years old  48 points the last 25 for the Cavaliers  by LeBron James  [Applause]  this point I'm going to take my towns to  Southern Beach and join the Miami News  [Music]  I'm LeBron James from Akron Ohio from  the inner city I'm not even supposed to  be here I'm blessed so what everybody  saying about me off the course don't  matter I ain't got no words  [Applause]  LeBron James with a rejection  [Applause]  when I decided to come here you know uh  just the excitement just to say like wow  you're a lake organization what they  respect Laker Nation want their respect  and I want my damn respect too LeBron  James is now number two  [Music]